[Applaus]
sommerurlaub mit tücken spanien gilt
wieder als corinna risikogebiet und in
deutschland geht der trend auf niedrigem
niveau wieder nach oben afghanistan
zurück in die vergangenheit das land
muss früher als erwartet ohne us-truppen
auskommen die taliban sind auf dem
vormarsch und kultur wieder live unter
freiem himmel die domstufen festspiele
in erfurt bieten opa und eine große
kulisse
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen guten freitag
abend hinein geben sie uns 20 minuten
für diesen nachrichtenüberblick kristin
otto ist auch hier mit dem sportler und
einem rekord einschenken
mitten in der urlaubssaison stufen die
deutschen behörden ganz spanien wieder
als crooner risikogebiet ein inklusive
kanaren und balearen die praktischen
auswirkungen für urlauber sind
überschaubar spaniens tourismus
ministerin kritisiert dass sich
deutschland dabei allein an der inzidenz
orientiert sie verliere an bedeutung
angesichts der hohen impfrate und der
niedrigen zahl an koma patienten in den
krankenhäusern
verglichen mit spanien hat deutschland
weiter nur sehr wenige neuinfektionen
doch die korona zahlen steigen leicht an
christoph distel frankfurt am main hat
eine große fußgängerzone einen flughafen
und wieder mehr corona inzidenz bei fast
ein deutscher spitzenwert der sich vom
aktuellen durchschnitt 5,5 deutlich
abhebt und das ohne den einen
infektionsherd nur durch verstreute
einzelfälle
das gesundheitsamt sieht keinen grund
für alarm für vorsicht aber schon
wir gehen den fällen nach und wir
unterbrechen die infektionsketten aber
wir wissen das entscheidende instrument
zum erfolg ist dass wir impfen impfen
auch die 5,5 für das ganze land sind
wieder ein anstieg was kommt da noch
fragen etwa die intensivmediziner mit
blick auf den herbst klingen dabei aber
ganz anders als noch im vergangenen
winter kein wort zu drohender
überlastung er eine dringende bitte an
das erst halb durch geimpfte land auch
entsprechend jetzt die
lockerungsmaßnahmen durchzuführen aber
eben zum beispiel in innenräumen nach
wie vor an eine maske tragen um eben zu
verhindern dass es viele unnötige
neuinfektionen gibt
die lage sei eben anders jetzt nachdem
impfangebot für fast alle stellen auch
die kassen ärzte klar noch ein lockdown
sei nicht mehr zu vermitteln
wir dürfen nicht in die alten
mechanismen verfallen und wieder alles
schließen wenn die inzidenz einsteigen
tun sie aber anderswo noch schneller
stichwort urlaub ganz spanien mitsamt
mallorca und den kanaren gilt ab heute
wieder als corona risikogebiet wer
hinfliegt tut das also gegen den rat der
regierung wenn auch ohne praktische
folgen für getestete geimpfte oder
genesene für alle quasi wenn sie
zurückkommen
inmitten der steigenden delta nervosität
meldet sich auch der impfstoffhersteller
bei sonntag zu wort studien hätten ja
gezeigt dass sechs monate nach der
zweiten spritze die schutzwirkung sinke
doch eine dritte dosis sagt biontech
jetzt führe zu deutlich mehr antikörpern
als die ersten beiden für drei dosen pro
körper müssen aber noch die behörden
grünes licht geben
es ist wieder viel möglich seit heute in
teilen von nordrhein westfalen liegt die
sieben tage incidents stabil unter 10
wird gelockert offiziell heißt das
incident stufe null und bedeutet es gibt
zum beispiel wieder volksfeste
sportveranstaltungen mit besuchern
offene diskotheken und clubs masken sind
nur noch pflicht in verkehrsmitteln und
läden
die opposition spricht von einem
gefährlichen wahlgeschenk tadeusz parade
berichtet ein dreiviertel jahr lang war
hier alles dicht jetzt werden wieder
stühle gerückt letzte vorbereitungen für
die heutige comedy show in der krefelder
kulturfabrik nach so langem stillstand
eine große herausforderung denn viele
mitarbeiter sind fort wir haben uns
einerseits sehr gefreut weil wir jetzt
ein ziel haben in dem wir arbeiten
können
aber natürlich waren wir überrascht dass
es jetzt so schnell gegangen ist
mit weniger als zehn neuinfektionen
gehört krefeld nach der neuen nrw corona
schutz verordnung zur intelligenz stufe
damit ist wieder ein leben fast ohne
einschränkungen möglich
die lockerungen in krefeld stoßen sie
auf geteiltes echo
man hat natürlich trotzdem angst wenn
man jetzt hört es kommt doch wieder was
rüber dass es so ein herbst richtung
wieder schlimmer wird deswegen sozi
gespalten ist wahrscheinlich vieles gut
wir sind geimpft
es ist alles niedrig alle werte sind
niedrig ich denke das ist so schnell es
geht wieder hoch und die leute werden
wieder unvorsichtig und also ich wissen
so gut auch wenn sie hier heute abend
spielen dürfen es könnte ein kurzes
vergnügen sein denn schon mit wenigen
neuinfektionen der ge krefeld wieder
über der 10 marke dann wäre schnell
wieder schluss mit der neu gewonnenen
freiheit und jetzt unser nächstes thema
heute abend in der sendung die lage in
afghanistan entwickelt sich brenzlig
ungeachtet dessen hat der us-präsident
gestern abend klar gemacht bis ende
august sollen die letzten us truppen das
land verlassen haben und die menschen
dort müssten nun allein über ihre
zukunft entscheiden
diese zukunft dürfte er ein zurück in
die vergangenheit sein denn die taliban
rücken vor
sie geben an dass sie inzwischen 85
prozent des landes beherrschen
so in etwa sieht das inzwischen wohl aus
die regierung kontrolliert nur noch die
gebiete in blau
die taliban haben die in rot erobert und
der rest ist umkämpft
auch die gebiete um kundus und masar i
scharif wo lange deutsche soldaten für
sicherheit sorgen sollten und
stationiert waren
katrin eigendorf berichtet
eine stadt in angst in masar i scharif
werden autos auf sprengstoff und
schusswaffen kontrolliert nur wenige
tage nach dem abzug der letzten
deutschen soldaten ist die region zum
kriegsgebiet geworden
die taliban sind zurück und feiern
selbstbewusst ihre eroberungen islam
carla ein wichtiger ort an der grenze zu
iran konnten sie einnehmen ohne dass die
armee widerstand leistete ist masar i
scharif die nächste stadt auf dem basar
fürchten viele händler um ihre zukunft
der grund ist dass die taliban immer
näher an die stadt heran rücken die
menschen haben angst niemand will mehr
einkaufen gehen die leute haben sogar
angst brot kaufen zu gehen im stich
gelassen fühlen sich viele afghanen ganz
besonders die die für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet haben
wir treffen nadschibullah ansari von
2011 bis 2012 hat er als dolmetscher
gearbeitet jetzt fürchtet er racheakte
der taliban
ich kann hier kein normales leben mehr
führen ich kann nicht arbeiten und ich
kann nicht in der stadt herumlaufen
ich muss dieses land verlassen ich
möchte von den deutschen truppen dass
sie uns an einen sicheren ort bringen
das deutsche konsulat inzwischen
geschlossen für die zurückgebliebenen
ortskräfte jetzt die frage an wen sollen
sie sich wenden afghanistan droht immer
weiter ins chaos zu stürzen auf sich
alleine gestellt ist die armee den
taliban nicht gewachsen
trotz jahrelanger ausbildung durch
westliche berater schlechte bezahlung
schlechte ausrüstung und angst der staat
verliert seinen wichtigsten rückhalt
militärische stärke
und wir kommen noch mal auf die
politische dimension des ganzen mit
glück war port in washington guten abend
wird us-präsident beiden jetzt sehenden
auges dabei zugucken wie afghanistan im
chaos endet im prinzip ja er klang
jedenfalls sehr defensiv gestern als er
sagte ein sieg der taliban sei so
wörtlich nicht unvermeidbar
das klingt jetzt nicht optimistisch aber
es ist ein eingeständnis dass dieser
krieg offenbar militärisch auch nach 20
jahren nicht zu gewinnen ist und beiden
hat wörtlich gesagt
auch wenn wir da noch jahrelang bleiben
es wird die situation nicht ändern
unsere mission war die gefahr durch al
kaida dort auszuschalten das haben wir
erreicht jetzt sind die afghanen dran
sie müssen jetzt selber über ihre
zukunft entscheiden
jetzt sagt der präsident also von
afghanistan gehe keine terroristische
gefahr mehr aus wie kommt er denn darauf
all die jahre wurde uns ja etwas ganz
anderes erzählt der präsident hat gesagt
dass die terroristische gefahr sich
verlagert hat und die usa müssten ihre
anstrengungen und auch ihre mittel in
sachen terrorismusbekämpfung jetzt auf
neue hotspots lenken wie zum beispiel
afrika aber auch südasien oder den nahen
und mittleren osten damit es natürlich
unter anderem iran gemeint er hat nicht
gesagt dass die gefahr komplett weg ist
aber er sagte unsere geheimdienste
halten das im auge wir werden dafür
sorgen dass aus afghanistan keine neue
terroristische bedrohung auf uns auf die
usa zukommt newport in washington mit
vielen dank für diese hintergrund
erläuterungen heute abend es war ein
kompromiss in letzter minute der
uno-sicherheitsrat verlängert die syrien
hilfen morgen wäre das mandat
ausgelaufen
mehr als dreieinhalb millionen menschen
in der provinz idlib sind auf
hilfslieferungen angewiesen
rund 1000 lastwagen pro monat bringen
lebensmittel trinkwasser und medikamente
ins land über den grenzübergang bad al
hawa der soll zwölf weitere monate
geöffnet bleiben russland enger
verbündeter von syriens machthaber
baschar al-assad hatte zuletzt darauf
gedrängt dass die grenze geschlossen
wird eine woche lang hat das
rettungsschiff ocean viking nach einem
hafen gesucht jetzt durfte es auf
sizilien anlegen und 572 geflüchtete
konnten an land gehen die menschen
stammen überwiegend aus afrika gut ein
viertel sind kinder und jugendliche die
allein die flucht über das mittelmeer
gewagt haben
schlauch und holzbooten die
eu-kommission hat angeboten die
verteilung der geretteten zu
koordinieren
noch ist offen ob peter r de vries den
kampf um sein leben gewinnt in einer
botschaft seiner familie heißt es sein
zustand ist unverändert vieles ist
ungewiss der 64-jährige
enthüllungsjournalist war am
dienstagabend mitten in amsterdam nach
dem auftritt in einer fernseh-talkshow
auf offener straße niedergeschossen
worden und schwer verletzt
zwei mutmaßliche täter sind gefasst und
sitzen in untersuchungshaft runder
krüger weiße rosen als unterstützung für
peter er de vries und zugleich als
vorwurf die regierung sei naiv im
angesicht des organisierten verbrechens
dienstagabend in den stadt kameras
überall
der passant esther fries den hier
ermorden will weiß er wird gefilmt und
doch vito szukala ist anwalt sein bester
kunde das organisierte verbrechen
sie sagen damit schau her die mafia
zeigt brutale stärke sie können alles
tun und glauben sie kommen davon
de vries ist journalist aber auch opfer
helfer er steht dem kronzeugen bei im
schwer bewachten und bisher größten
strafprozess der niederlande
redouane t ist der angeklagte sechs
morde der tatvorwurf gegen ihn und seine
bande kam der auftrag zum mord an de
vries aus der haft man sagt schon länger
peter er de vries stehe auf der
abschussliste
da braucht es nicht mal einen anrufer es
gibt immer einen der dafür geld kassiert
noch am dienstag stellte die polizei
zwei männer ein richter entschied nun
der 21 jährige mutmaßliche schütze und
der 35 jährige fahrer des fluchtautos
bleiben in haft
am nachmittag lädt amsterdams größte
kirche zur fürbitte die tat löst bei
vielen fassungslosigkeit aus aber man
merkt auch viel liebe wir sind stolz auf
so einen mann wie peter er de vries der
für recht und gerechtigkeit steht
derweil lässt die familie des opfers
verlauten sein zustand sei weiter
kritisch
zurück zu uns nach deutschland wurde der
wahlkampf läuft 79 tage noch zeit für
sie zu entscheiden bei wem sie am 26
september ihr kreuz machen bei der wahl
zum neuen deutschen bundestag
neben den etablierten parteien gibt es
eine ganze reihe weiterer die ins rennen
um den sprung auf den wahlzettel gingen
zugelassen wurden heute parteien von
ganz links bis ganz rechts der
bundeswahlausschuss hatte geprüft ob sie
die formalen voraussetzungen zur
teilnahme an der wahl erfüllen wie zum
beispiel ein pünktlich abgegebene
rechenschaftsbericht andreas künast hat
sich ein paar spezielle kandidaten
angeschaut
hier kommen weiter zur laufenden nummer
12 als nummer zwölf sitzt vor dem
bundeswahlausschuss die partei
ganzheitliches recht auf leben und es
gibt ein problem
stimmt denn diese angabe von vier
mitgliedern noch das sind inzwischen
wohl mehr
aber ich kann ihnen im moment auch keine
genauen zahlen nennen wenn das meer im
einstelligen bereich meer wo im
einstelligen bereich
vier mitglieder vielleicht mehr
teilnahme an der bundestagswahl
abgelehnt
auch die partei die natürlichen bekommt
ein nein bei der anhörung im bundestag
die partei bundes zentralrat der
schwarzen in deutschland formfehlern 1
die baath partei über partei
zusatzbezeichnung öko anarchisten
statistische sammelbecken bekommt ein
jahr für mich auch sehr gut auf roma von
den pinken bis zur v partei für
veränderung vegetarier und veganer 44
kleinparteien werden zugelassen 43 nicht
die anarchistische pogo partei
deutschlands kpd scheitert weil ire
beteiligungs anzeige nicht
vorschriftsgemäß unterzeichnet ist
die deutsche demokratie scheint am leben
aber auch anstrengend zu sein die pogo
parteivorsitzenden etwa ärgert sehr
sagen sie dass sie heute extra nüchtern
geblieben sind bunte republik
deutschland
und jetzt endlich wieder kunst auf
großer bühne
die altstadt von erfurt strahlt heute
abend eine farbexplosion auf dom und
severikirche als sei die kunst heraus
geplatzt die so lange wegen corona
weggesperrt war es ist das theater das
zurückkehrt und die 70 stufen der
historischen kulisse in einer opulenten
opernbühne verwandelt premiere für die
jungfrau von orléans daniela sonntag
johanna von alea einnahme eingeschrieben
in die europäische geschichte und jetzt
auf den erfurter domstufen
zum ersten mal seit corona wieder eine
eigene opernproduktion hier mit der
musik von peter tschaikowsky und
begeisterten darsteller
[Musik]
dramatisch deshalb mag ich es ist
dramatisch es ist tragisch es ist
bewegend ich liebe es sehr diese rolle
zu spielen
ein bauernmädchen dass die französischen
truppen den kampf gegen die engländer
anführt und für ihren könig siegt
[Musik]
sonntag von göttlichen stimmen berufen
auf den domstufen eine treppe in den
himmel als bühne und die helden ein
vorbild bis heute starke frauenfiguren
wissen vielmehr auf die bühne und
deswegen nicht dass er gutes saal hier
ist ich bin begeistert das spiel auch
mit dem licht weiß und dann schwarz als
ich das öffnete sehr sehr gute coruna
bedingt nur die hälfte der
zuschauerplätze in erfurt dafür aber
technische neuerungen das orchester live
aus dem theater übertragen
dadurch entsteht ein total neues
klangerlebnis viel schöner viel präzise
viel runder
also das ist schon toll
die jungfrau von orléans scheitert am
ende verbrannt als hexe tschaikowskys
russische oper als denkmal für eine
große frau auf den erfurter domstufen
ja toll dass es das wiedergibt jetzt der
sport kristin otto und wir gucken nach
frankreich zuerst auf der 13 etappe der
tour de france hat der brite mark
cavendish geschafft mit seinem insgesamt
34 tages sie gleich zu ziehen mit dem
legendären rekordhalter eddy merckx aus
belgien klug eingefädelt von seinem team
clever gelöst
der mann in grün scheint beim zielsprint
schon abgehängt aber mit teamwork und
timing fängt er die konkurrenz noch ab
total erschöpft sogar später beim
interview ich bin also sehr kaputt 220
kilometer in dieser hitze und dem wind
und dann so ein finale
ein defekt zuvor kostet sogar noch zeit
und doch in carcassonne schreibt der 36
jährige brite geschichte zieht gleich
mit eddy merckx die sprinter wertung ist
ihm kaum noch zu nehmen
weitere absage für die deutsche
olympische fußball mannschaft der männer
niklasdorf einer der jungen
leistungsträger verzichtet wegen seines
wechsels zum bundesligaverein fc
augsburg der fca hat bereits zwei
spieler für tokio abgestellt und noch
zum tennis da steht erstmalig ein
italiener im finale von wimbledon matteo
ricci viva italia in london
matteo contini hat es der italienischen
seria zu da mit dem final einzug in
wimbledon gleich getan
sein gegner der pole hubert uhr touch
mit den siegen gegen medwedew und
federer angetreten sieht sich heute ganz
einfach einen stärkeren gegner gegenüber
ganz gleich was der 24-jährige aus
breslau auch versucht fast immer hat
betty nie die bessere antwort parat
nach gut zweieinhalb stunden beendet der
italiener in vier sätzen ein ziemlich
einseitiges match und macht den
kommenden sonntag in wimbledon und wenig
später auch in wembley zu einem großen
italienischen sport feiertag in der tat
fußball und tennis spannend wird die
italiener das kannst du dort sollen
neben christine so und jetzt müssen sie
sehr tapfer sein denn wir haben noch ein
paar sommerbilder für sie das ist der
landkreis hof heute sommer bloß unter
dem braun das ist die landschaft das
graue über den braun der himmel soll mal
blau gewesen sein aber das war wohl ein
anderer sommer das gute es nicht immer
und überall so aber immer mal wieder was
uns zum wetter für morgen bringt
bisschen deprimiert die bilder aber
morgen mal fast kein regen jedenfalls
vormittags wie es dann nachmittags und
sonntag und überhaupt weitergeht erklärt
gleich katja horneffer heute-journal
zeit ist heute 22 uhr mit der kollegin
marietta slomka uns gibt's morgen wieder
um punkt 7 des dann wenn sie mögen aber
erst von uns allen hier einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
guten abend es sind die langsam
ziehenden tiefs die enorme regenmengen
mitbringen können in einer stunde kann
da durchaus 30 liter regen pro
quadratmeter fallen
dieses tief zieht jetzt allerdings
weiter nach norden und deswegen fällt in
der nacht vor allen dingen noch so
zwischen dem erzgebirge und ostsee regen
zum teil ist er auch mit gewitter
durchmischt aber bis zum frühen morgen
lassen die regenfälle mehr und mehr nach
sonst ist es häufig klar und es bildet
sich auch mal nebel oder dunst sind es
wird zum teil recht kühl
die temperaturen sinken auf 13 bis 8
grad und nur hier ganz im osten und im
norden bleibt es bei 17 bis 14 grad
etwas milder
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen im
angenehmen bereich meist um die 24 grad
etwas kühler ist es an der küste wärme
an der donau oder auch am oberrhein
und dazu passt auch der wohlfühl
vormittag sonnenschein und wolken
wechseln sich ab die letzten schauer
verabschieden sich schnell
nachmittags allerdings kommt schon das
nächste tieferen bringt regen und zum
teil sogar schon wieder die ersten
gewitter mit am sonntag zieht dann
dieser regen mit den gewittern weiter
nach nordosten
da wird es hier im südwesten ganz
freundlich die temperaturen steigen auf
22 bis 27 grad und die neue woche die
startet wieder mit gewittern
guten abend